-Thank you for being
my first guest in the year 2022.
Thank you. I'm honored.
I'm honored.
-Thank you. Thank you.
It's going to be a good year.
-You know it.
It's going to be -- Yeah.
Do you typically make
any New Year's resolution?
-To be a better person
than what I was last year.
-How is that possible with you?
-It's possible.
I fall short sometimes.
Yeah, I fall short.
-Do you really?
-It's like "Oh, I'm going to eat
healthier. I'm going to do this.
I'm going to lose weight."
No, I never stuck to that stuff.
-No.
I figure if I just say
I'll be a better person,
a better father, better friend,
better son, better whatever,
I can stick to that.
-I like that.
That's awesome.
-Yeah.
-I do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Happy to come back.
I love when you're here.
Obviously, the audience,
we love you too,
but I want to talk to you
about this,
because you went to Dubai
recently.
-I did.
-Now, how did you end up there,
and what's going on in Dubai?
-Steve Harvey is
a very good friend of mine.
-Love Steve.
-And he had his celebrity
golf tournament there,
you know,
for his various charities.
And so he invited us over,
so we all went over there, man.
And it was a great time.
It was me, Yvonne Orji
from "Insecure."
Ahmad Rashad.
-Yes.
-Akon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, right?
-Akon plays golf?
-Akon, yeah. Well, well!
[ Laughter ]
I'm not going to say that.
And I got an issue with this.
Akon has never played golf
before in his life, right?
[ Laughter ]
Never played golf before
in his life.
-Yeah.
-But won the tournament.
-That's my man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
-That's my man.
-No, no, no.
Alright, so, he came --
his team came in first.
Steve Harvey's team
came in second.
My team didn't even place
at all.
[ Laughter ]
But this is it.
Akon was playing ahead of me.
And Steve and his team
were playing behind me.
So I got to see how horrible
both these teams were.
-Yeah.
-And they both --
One took first place, one took
second -- third place.
And I didn't place at all.
-It's rigged.
-Yeah, very much so.
I'm not going to say it was
rigged, but it was rigged.
[ Laughter ]
-What is Dubai like?
I've seen pictures.
What is Dubai?
-Dubai is unlike any other city
that I've been in, man.
They say it's the city
of the future.
When I was there a few weeks
ago, it was --
they're having the World Expo
there, which is the first time
it's been held in a Muslim
country, which was beautiful.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's still going on.
And it was also World Day.
It was their birthday.
Dubai's only 50. I'm 51.
I'm older than Dubai.
-Wow! That's interesting.
-I'm older than Dubai.
-But you're back in New York
for a little bit?
-I'm back in New York
for a little bit. A lot of bit.
-I'm excited about this.
-So am I, man.
-You're doing "Law & Order"
again.
-Back to "Law & Order."
Detective Kevin Bernard.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on, bud!
-Yeah.
-Dude, this is big.
-Yeah, yeah.
-How does it feel to come back?
-It feels great, man.
I'm back in a well-worn saddle
that just grips your ass.
-There you go. That's exactly
the way to put it. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-It's fun to have you
back on NBC.
This is going to be fun, bud.
-Yeah, good to be back.
-And New York.
-Yeah.
-We got to hang out,
figure out something.
How's Mom doing,
first and foremost,
'cause you know
I love your mother.
-Mom is doing great.
-Doris.
-Yeah, Mama Doris
is doing great.
She's single now, thanks to our
last appearance on your show.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-No, because of that?
-Those who remember,
it don't work!
-No, he didn't like it?
-He didn't.
He never called my mama
after that night.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, man, why you laughing?!
He never called --
My mom was so excited.
She was like, "Baby, baby.
Look, me and Anthony had fun
with your -- at your expense
on 'Fallon' tonight,
but watch the show."
To this day he hasn't called
my mama back, Fallon.
-Ah!
-So this what you got to do.
When I bring my mama
to New York,
we got to set my mama up
on a new date.
-Oh, of course. Doris, easy.
-Alright.
You hear that, Mama?
-Easy-peasy.
And, Doris, we don't need him
anyway 'cause it didn't work.
-Stop, man! Stop!
[ Laughter ]
But it don't work!
-I heard your mom is doing --
I heard your mom is doing
something with Eddie Murphy.
-She is, man.
We both are, but my mom is
in Eddie Murphy's new movie
with Jonah Hill
and a bunch of other people.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
You know, everybody always,
"Does your mom get star-struck?"
I was like, "Yeah and no.
She plays it cool."
She was in a scene with Eddie
and one of the A.D.s says,
"Ah! I think we have to
do it again."
And out of nowhere, my mama
said, "[Bleep] I hope we don't."
[ Laughter ]
And Eddie Murphy turned to him
and was like, "Was that
Anthony Anderson's mama?"
He was like, "Yeah."
He said, "Man, she is funny!"
[ Laughter ]
-I love it.
Hey, Mom, we're setting you up
when you come back to New York.
-Hopefully with somebody
who works.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
When we come back, I want to
talk about the final season
of "Black-ish" and also about
having Michelle Obama
on your show.
More with Anthony Anderson
when we come back.
Come on back, everybody.